Major breaking news as an insane ruling
against the Second Amendment came out of
America's worst possible court when it
comes to our right to keep and bear
arms. That's right. That's the US Court
appeals for the first circuit out of
Boston. Just a crazy court, a bunch of
nutty liberals is the reality on the
ground and everyone understands that's
why the Supreme Court keeps reversing
them on immigration cases. But on this
one, the case of Beckwith versus Frey,
guess what? They screwed up the Second
Amendment in terms of upholding a
72-hour waiting period by the state of
Maine. I wonder if they'd uphold a law
that says you have to wait 72 hours to
register to vote or 72 hours to buy a
book or 72 hours to publish a paper or
72 hours to, I don't know, post on X.
I'm guessing not. But let's break down
this crazy decision. Three to zero.
Three anti-gun judges par for the course
out of Boston, Massachusetts. The home
of Michelle Woo and the home of the
great Somali that made that city great
again apparently according to the mayor.
Let's break it all down when we come
right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box, proud American gun owner,
constitutional attorney, member of the
United States Supreme Court Bar, and I'm
proud to say the top voice of the Second
Amendment in America. Thank you. 2025
and 2026 gun news awards. All right. So,
we have another typical but insane
anti-second amendment ruling out of
Boston. The typical US Court of Appeals
for the First Circuit, which as I've
trained you and taught you is the 100%
worst court in America. There's no
combination of three judges on any three
judge panel that you could possibly get
that would respect, oh, I don't know,
America and the Constitution out of that
court. It makes the Ninth Circuit look
like a court full of Clarence Thomas'.
That's how bad the first circuit is out
of Boston, the home of Steven Brier.
That's right. Okay. So, with that said,
let's break down what happened here. We
had a main law that was enacted after a
mass shooting. Now, of course, the mass
shooting had nothing to do with a waning
period or any delays. The guy was just a
wackadoodle nut job uh and went out
there and did terrible things, I
believe, in another gun-free zone.
Typical typical, right? Nevertheless,
Maine had to do something. And what they
decided to do was, of course, to punish
ordinary gun owners by implementing a
blanket 72-hour waiting period, 3-day
waiting period for everyone, unless of
course you work for the government.
Because if you work for the government,
you're a miracle. You're a special
snowflake. You don't have to abide by
the rest of the rules that we in America
live by because you're special since you
get a W2 form every year from the
government. So anyway, if you weren't
working for the government or related to
the government, you were subject to the
72-hour window, which basically said
that if you buy a firearm, you had to
wait 3 days uh between the time you
acquire bought the gun, legally bought
the gun with an agreement, and the time
you could take possession of this. All
of course in the name of preventing, you
know, selfdeion, if you will, and other
acts of passion, all the typical
nonsense we've seen for many decades out
of the anti-gun movement. Uh,
nevertheless, that was what happened
here. So, with that said, the district
court judge in Maine did basically a
very good analysis and said, "Look, the
restriction or burden of a 3-day waiting
period that's just willy-nilly on
everyone that wants to buy a gun is
clearly unconstitutional because under
the plain text of the Second Amendment,
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed. In order to
keep a gun, in order to carry a gun, in
order to bear a gun, guess what? Hello.
You need to acquire the gun, right? You
can't keep a gun or carry a gun if you
don't have a gun, which means you have
the right to acquire a gun. And how do
most people acquire guns? Oh, I don't
know. They buy them at a store the same
way they acquire things like tomatoes
and groceries and cars and all sorts of
other things. They go to a dealer and
buy the item. Nevertheless, Maine says
you have to wait 3 days unless you work
for the government. And guess what? The
district court judge says, "Yeah, that
violates the second amendment because as
a matter of plain text, your burden in
the right, right, the conduct that is
being described here are really
restricted by the law is the ability to
go and buy a gun to exercise your second
amendment rights. And as a consequence
of this, the plain text of the second
amendment has been implicated. And when
the plain text of the second amendment
has been implicated by a modern day gun
control law, meaning the activity that
you want to engage in uh falls within
the scope of the plain text of the
second amendment, guess what happens?
You know what happens? The burden
shifts. The burden shifts to the
government to do what? Well, that means
basically the government's law is
unconstitutional unless the government
can come forth with long-standing
historical traditions of laws going back
to the founding 1791 when the second one
was adopted to show that whatever the
restriction is in modern day America is
consistent with that long-standing
regulatory history of firearms
regulation going back to 1791. So when
the district court anal analyzed all
this, they said, well, obviously going
back to 1791, there was no absurd notion
that everyone that wanted to buy a gun
to exercise their fundamental natural
right to self-defense, to exercise their
second right to keep and bear arms.
There was no such thing as just a
blanket 3-day waiting period just
because. Just because. Right. There's no
individualized determination that says,
"Well, I don't know, you're a criminal,
you're this, you're that." No, no,
nothing like that. It's just like
everyone in America has to comply with
this 3day window. There's no such thing
like that. And of course, the district
court judge having made that
determination showing that there was no
evidence or no historical record of this
kind of a long-standing law said that
the main law was unconstitutional. and
he then enjoined it because I should
note that this case was immediately
filed and they sought a preliminary
injunction and the district court judge
did grant the preliminary injunction and
said I'm not going to let Maine enforce
this law because it clearly violates the
second amendment. So the state of Maine
of course took an an appeal with it with
the typical support of the anti-gun laws
to the anti-gun lawyers, the anti-gun
groups and you know the usual suspects
and of course you had three judges. One
was appointed by Barack Obama and two
were appointed by Joe Biden. So what are
the odds of this court coming out in
favor of the Second Amendment no matter
what happens? That would be about 0%.
And of course in this 3 to zero decision
by two Biden judges and a Obama judge.
Of course they came out three to zero
that this does not um impact the Second
Amendment and therefore it is
constitutional. But there's some insane
reasoning here that you're not going to
believe which you're going to get to in
just one second. But before we get to
that, we know whenever you start off
with an opinion dealing with the Second
Amendment, and right off the bat, the
judges start talking about the misuse of
firearms, right off the bat, you know,
and I know it's going down a bad path.
And that's exactly what happened in the
opening part of this decision, this
opinion in the case of Beck versus Fry.
um they talk about how this law that
they're litigating or at least
considering the constitutionality
thereof arose from a mass shooting. So
again, if you immediately start talking
about people misusing arms uh in the
start of your opinion, you basically
know what you're going to get. You're
going to get an anti-gun brief
masquerading as a judicial opinion
because you're not supposed to consider
the misuse of fires because the truth is
there's nothing in America you cannot
misuse. You can misuse your right to go
to church. You can misuse your religious
freedom. You can misuse your ability to
speak. You can misuse your right to
vote. You misuse your right to write.
You see what I'm saying? You can misuse
anything at all. But that's not how we
measure what is constitutionally
protected by virtue of how some
whackadoodle psychopathic nut job
misuses something. Anyone can do that.
It can happens with any right or any
object or anything. But that is not how
we define rights. The fact that some
wackadoodle can go out there and misuse
a firearm does not a basis for taking
away my right to keep environments and
narrowing the scope thereof.
Nevertheless, of course, this three
judge panel of Barack Obama judge plus
two buying judges start off right off
the bat talking about mass shootings
because of course they do. What else do
they have? But then they go on and talk
about in several pages and here's the
funniest thing that several paragraphs
going over multiple pages. They
basically describe the notion of
selfdeion and how supposedly uh the use
of or these these waiting periods
somehow make it harder for people to
self-deeote themselves andor prevent
crimes of passion and or cause people to
grab this and go out and do terrible
crimes as opposed to people that just
you know simply plan ahead. Right? So,
but nevertheless, the fact that this
opinion is talking all about these sorts
of things again speaks to tears of
scrutiny and interest balancing, which
the Supreme Court has said is verboten.
And just to jog your memory, tears of
scrutiny or interest balancing mean the
same thing, which essentially goes along
these lines. Even assuming that a law in
a modern day America infringes upon a
constitutional right such as the second
amendment, even if that is the case, the
government is still able to win and
uphold its law and restrict your rights
if the government can show it has a
really really good reason for
restricting your rights. And the Supreme
Court said in the context of the Second
Amendment, that kind of argument, that
kind of reasoning is not allowed. That
kind of reasoning is allowed in the
context of the first amendment right to
free speech only because we had decades
and decades and decades of insane
anti-American liberal judicial activism
that is kind of on the books as black
letter law today and it's been on the
books for decades and it's not that easy
for the Supreme Court to get away from
that although you don't know what the
future holds. We'll see. But when it
comes to the second amendment, that kind
of um barnacles from left-wing judicial
activism is not on the law books and
therefore interest balancing is not
allowed in the context of the second
amendment. The Supreme Court's made that
clear repeatedly. Nevertheless, here you
have the US Court of Appeals for the
First Circuit out of Boston talking all
about the good positive social science
and public policy benefits associated
with these kinds of waiting periods.
Again, speaking of the fact that the way
they did the methodology here to decide
this wrongly uh was flawed in many ways.
And just to show you how crazy this
opinion is, let me read part of this and
then we'll break it down. Here's what
the Beckworth opinion out of the First
Circuit had to say. The Brewing test
requires first that a court determine
whether the Second Amendment's plain
text covers an individual's conduct. If
yes or if so, the Burn shifts to the
government to demonstrate that the
regulation is consistent with this
nation's historical tradition of
firearms regulation. If not, the
regulated conduct is categorically
unprotected.
The Brewing Court indicated, however,
that categorically unprotected does not
mean immune entirely from the Second
Amendment scrutiny. Laws that regulate
conduct that is outside the Second
Amendment's plain text, but nevertheless
burden a person's right to keep him arms
are only presumptively constitutional.
Such laws may still violate the Second
Amendment if the regulated part shows
that the laws are being put toward an
abuse of ends. What the hell are they
talking about? Let's just think about
what they just said. They said if
conduct,
you want to own a gun, you want to carry
a gun, you want to shoot a gun, you want
to train with a gun, see the Isel case
out of the seventh circuit, whatever it
is,
if you want to do these activities as an
American citizen,
then it obviously is covered by the
second amendment. The right to keep
arms. It has all these concominant
rights, these ancillary rights, right?
the right to acquire guns. You can't
keep them arms without being able to buy
the guns. You have to be able to train
with the guns. Again, the AEL case out
of the Seven Circuit says that you got
to be able to buy bullets. You got to be
able to buy, you know, parts to the
guns. You got to be able to maintain the
guns. You see what I'm saying? There's
all sorts of things that go along
naturally and intrinsically with the
right to keep arms. Nevertheless, what
this court is literally saying is that
there are instances where things that
might fall outside of the plain text,
the Second Amendment, might still be
protected by the Second Amendment under
some sort of under standard. Now, this
makes no sense cuz think about what they
just said there. They're basically said
here that laws that regulate conduct
that is outside the Second Amendment's
plain text, but nevertheless burden a
person's right to keep and bear arms are
only presumptively constitutional.
All right. You see what what they just
did there? How crazy it is? They said
that conduct that's outside of the plain
text, the Second Amendment,
may still possibly burden the right to
keep and bear arms.
But this is crazy, right? Because
obviously if something burns a person
right to keep and bear arms, by
definition, it must fall within the
plain text of the Second Amendment.
Because if it burns the person's right
to keep arms, it falls within the
language of the right of people to keep
arms shall not be infringed. And
therefore, it's covered by the plain
text of the Second Amendment. And if
that regulation um that's involved or
the regulation that's promagated today
touches fingers with conduct that falls
within the plain text of the Second
Amendment, the burn shifts to the
government to show there's a
long-standing historical tradition that
it's constitutional.
And yet here you have on page nine, you
got to take a look at this. It's crazy.
You have a court saying that there's
instances where things are protected or
covered by the second amendment but not
covered by the plain text. It's not even
possible to assert that with a straight
face. It's just another example in my
view of this first circuit court of
appeals tying itself into knots to avoid
admitting that the plain text step of
the brew methodology is a significant
hurdle. And once it's satisfied, the
burn shifts to the government. And the
reality is the government is not going
to be able to show there is any
historical tradition of just a blanket
3-day waiting period for acquiring a
handgun anymore. There is no historical
tradition for a 3-day waiting period
before you can post online before you
can write an op-ed, before you can vote,
before you can get a voter ID, before
you can speak, before you can protest
any of these things. If you did a
three-day waiting period before I could
go buy a book or a magazine or a
newspaper and all my news is three or
four days late, how would that fly? It
would not fly very well very well. And
by the way, as a as a bit of irony here,
the judge that wrote this opinion, uh,
Judge uh A-frame, I think it's
pronounced Seth A-frame, uh, guess what?
He actually teaches First Amendment law
at the University of New Hampshire.
Crazy stuff, right? And yet, of course,
he bollockses it up six ways the sun. In
fact, it's so bad that on one of the
later pages of this opinion, judge a
frame literally quotes and cites to a
a 1996 law review article talking about
the infringement of fundamental rights.
What's the problem with signing to a law
review article from 1996? Oh, I don't
know. That would be literally 12 years
12 years before the Supreme Court
decided HELLER
AND DECADES OLD. So he's literally
citing something from ancient Greece
that has no applicability today at all
because the Supreme Court has basically
REJECTED ALL OF WHAT IS being suggested
in the context of Second Amendment
jurist prunes. And yet this court
literally assigned to 1996 authority to
interpret the Supreme Court's decision
from 2008 through today.
Insane. It just goes to show you how
this court is bending over backwards to
rule against the Second Amendment
because they hate guns and they're from
Boston. To make it even worse, this
court literally says that the right to
acquire guns doesn't touch fingers with
the right to keep and bear. Here's what
they write. Believe it or not, we agree
with the attorney general's view that
the laws regulating the purchase or
acquisition of firearms do not target
conduct covered by the Second
Amendment's plain text. The amendment's
plain text guarantees an individual's
ability to keep and bear arms, which
means to have and carry guns. The act
does not address this conduct. Rather,
the act imposes a limitation in some
circumstances on when a person can
acquire a firearm after the person
purchased it. The act thus regulates
conduct that occurs before a person
keeps or carries a gun. Accordingly,
applying Bruins plain text analysis, the
act imposes conditions and
qualifications on a commercial sale of
firearms that do not directly restrict
the textual right protected by the
second amendment. Now, that's crazy,
right? Because again,
if I literally deny you the ability for
3 days to acquire a gun, what have I
done? I've imposed a gun ban on you for
3 days. I've said you can't have a gun
for 3 days. Period. That is a gun ban.
Now, it may only be three for three
days, but it's a gun ban. Moreover, you
would never apply this with any other
constitutional right. And of course,
whatever you want to say, if I hinder
your ability to exercise a fundamental
constitutional right, such as the right
to keep marriage for 3 days, I'm
hindering your ability to exercise a
right. Which means that the whole
question falls under the plain text of
the second amendment and the burn system
of the government. But there is simply
no historical tradition of requiring
everyone that wants to acquire a gun and
to exercise their right to keep members
to wait 3 days just because the
government wants you to wait for three
days. I don't even think there were
waiting periods of any sort until very
very late in the 20th century. Certainly
nothing in the 18th century to speak of.
And to the extent there's any
restrictions on the ability to acquire
gun at the time of the founding, those
always turn on individualized
determinations that you were a danger to
yourself or to someone else in the
context item like shy laws. But whatever
you want to say about those, none of
them are analogous to just telling
everyone that wants to exercise a
fundamental right, you got to wait 3
days JUST BECAUSE WE WANT YOU TO. All
right, so I'm going to put a link to the
opinion in the description of this
video. I know it's crazy. Check it out.
Um, I think there's a very good chance
the Supreme Court might take this case.
I think there may be a split of
authority there with the 10th Circuit
now. Uh, but again, this is the kind of
thing the Supreme Court might
potentially per curium it with a few
paragraphs saying that you screwed up
the methodology so badly you got to redo
it. We'll see what happens. Uh, the
attorney for the Second Amendment rights
advocates here or rights claimments here
are Aaron Murphy and Paul Clement. Very
strong attorneys. they might be able to
pull off some magic with the US Supreme
Court in this case because it's pretty
clear that the uh first circuit messed
this up six ways to Sunday.
Nevertheless, I appreciate you tuning
in. Make sure you follow me over there
on X for BBOX and Dire. Don't forget to
subscribe both YouTube and Roma and I'll
see you all again soon here at you
guessed it for boxes.
>> Orders up table 2 A.